the white house has no idea what joe
biden does on a daily basis jin saki
yesterday was asked what joe biden was
doing you know while russia was
threatening ukraine's border and while
inflation was running out of control so
so here was jensaki's answer as to what
joe biden was doing yesterday
so the president has nothing on his
schedule today aside from the pdb can
you shed any light on how he's spending
his day
uh well let's see um this morning i
think he had some policy meetings also a
pdb meeting
he
later this afternoon i think is doing
some
remarks review there are some days that
we spend some time uh doing internal
meetings and discussions uh with policy
experts with policy leaders um and
that's that's what's happening today
so much is happening today actually what
was biden doing yesterday who's getting
ice cream
so uh yeah there's joe eating ice cream
because this is what makes him popular
is being incompetent and and half senile
and eating lots of ice cream so that's
exciting also this administration laser
focused on the problems of the people
here was kamala harris the wildly
unpopular vice president yesterday
talking about where this administration
has put its focus
we are focused on the most vulnerable
and based on my experience the most
vulnerable
are women and girls
racial and ethnic minorities
lgbtqi plus people
indigenous people
people with disabilities migrants
and children in the foster care system
when we identify who is most vulnerable
we can tailor our tactics
and improve our strategy
so all of their tactics are tailored
toward the most vulnerable which
includes the majority of american
citizens i like how she just throws
women in there women are the most
vulnerable women out earn men straight
out of college right now okay women have
far more college degrees than men do
they have more graduate degrees than men
do women are among the victimized when
you add women just
women
as a category to that litany of the
victimized in american society she's now
talking about about 70 of the american
population right all racial minorities
and all women that would be like 70 of
the american population basically she
should have just had everyone who is not
a straight white male everyone is not a
straight white male is a victim in our
society
and she's saying this from her purchase
vice president of the united states
saying we are going to direct policy to
the benefit of these specific groups
which actually suggests that the people
who are the victims of the kamala harris
joe biden administration are the
straight white males and she's
explicitly saying the only people she is
not governing on behalf of are the
straight white males which is pretty
astonishing so it's a good thing things
are things are going great for the for
the biden administration just across the
board just astonishingly well meanwhile
joe biden did take a break from eating
ice cream yesterday to say that russia
invading ukraine could change the world
that would be the biggest invasion since
world war ii um he's not wrong about
that the only question is why he set up
an incentive structure so that russia
would invade ukraine again
there will be enormous consequences
if he were to go in and invade as he
could the entire country
or a lot less than that as well
for russia not only in terms of
economic consequences and political
consequences but will be enormous
consequences worldwide
this would be the largest if he were to
move in with all those forced to be the
largest invasion since world war ii it
would change the world
okay now biden has started to make some
moves that are a little more aggressive
yesterday he was not going to rule out
sanctioning vladimir putin personally so
freezing foreign bank accounts although
vlad is not really going to care i mean
he's hidden his money in a variety of
places including places that the west
does not have control over here is joe
biden saying yesterday that he's not
going to rule out sanctioning vladimir
putin personally
watching one of you on television
pointing out the fact that uh
i think you've got it right whoever it
was i'm embarrassed i don't remember who
saying that this is all putin i don't
think even his people know for certain
what he's going to do would you ever see
yourself personally sanctioning him if
he did invade ukraine
yes
you would i would see that
okay in positive moves and you got to
give credit where it's due the bite
administration did announce on tuesday
it would work with gas and crude oil
suppliers from the middle east north
africa and asia to bolster supplies to
europe in the coming weeks should russia
try to cut off fuel shipments in the
escalating conflict over ukraine
according to the new york times european
allies have been cautious in public
about how far they would go in placing
severe sanctions on moscow if it invades
ukraine germany has been especially wary
because the germans can always be
counted upon to side with the world's
worst humans in conflict of this sword
okay with that said you know what had
been a lot easier is if we had not
greenlit the nordstrom 2 pipeline and
allowed europe to become significantly
more dependent on the on the russian
natural gas and oil industry that
definitely would have been a lot better
to start meanwhile the when it comes to
the the ukraine situation the good news
is that this administration is so in
control of themselves that uh they are
mocking donald trump so peter ducey
or as joe biden calls him that son of a
peter ducey asked the biden
administration asked shinsaki about
whether a hashtag has ever stopped an
authoritarian since it seems like this
administration is very into hashtag
diplomacy so here is gensake turning
that around and trying to ridicule
donald trump over it
the secretary of state a few days ago
tweeted
i hashtag
stand with ukraine
has that ever worked
at stopping an authoritarian regime from
doing anything a hashtag
i will have to say that unlike the last
administration we don't think twitter is
the only means of engaging or
negotiating or discussing important
topics
okay well that's not true
i mean i'm sorry but that's not true it
was barack obama's administration where
jen saki was holding up the hashtag
freer girls or whatever it was with
regard to boko haram so hashtag
diplomacy started under barack obama but
of course it is always about trump and
trump and nothing else because they've
got nothing else i mean meanwhile
they're just releasing single migrants
into the united states according to the
new york post dozens of single mostly
male adult migrants were shuttled from a
makeshift processing center in texas to
a local airport for flights to various
united states cities marking the first
time such transfer has been captured on
video amid the ongoing border crisis
according to a report on tuesday the
scene began unfolding sunday outside a
parking garage in brownsville where a
makeshift processing center was set up
in a vacant office according to fox news
a video recording shows a line of men
and women being escorted into the office
after which some of them left and got
into taxi cabs that arrived to pick them
up fox news said it followed the cab's
valley international airport in
harlingen about 30 minutes away where
some of the migrants reportedly said
they'd been smuggling across the border
with mexico after paying a criminal
cartel two thousand bucks apiece the
migrants said they were hand headed to
atlanta houston and miami according to
fox news
that revelation came one day after
updated figures from u.s customs and
border protection showed that more than
000 migrants were apprehended at the
southern border
last month
almost 200 000 migrants were apprehended
at the southern border last month the
highest number for any december on
record
the figure is higher than the total
number of migrants 175 000 stopped
during the past three decembers combined
combined
so you by the way you notice which
cities these migrants are going to
atlanta houston miami in other words
southern cities with jobs that is where
they are going
the shuttling of migrants into the
interior of the united states echoes a
new york post report last year in which
plane loads of underage migrants were
flown into the westchester county
airport north of new york city
the post saw some of those children
transported in buses to a nonprofit
residential center on long island and to
a service area on the new jersey
turnpike where they were met by
unidentified adults and driven away in
cars
fox news said what it witnessed was
unusual because single adult migrants
typically are expelled from the united
states under a federal law known as
title 42 which allows the government to
deny people entry to prevent the spread
of covenant 19.
trump invoked title 42 after the
covenant 19 pandemic struck and joe
biden continued the practice so jen saki
was asked about this why are we now
releasing single migrants into the
united states why are hundreds of
thousands of migrants arriving on
america's southern border under joe
biden by the way all these people are
arriving because they know they'll never
be deported because joe biden is never
going to deport illegal immigrants
period end of story he wants the border
open he wants
the census data to reflect a huge number
of migrants from countries south of the
border because his presumption is
whether it's accurate or not his
presumption is that these people will
vote democrat that is joe biden's
presumption that is the reason he's not
closing the border he has every ability
to turn people away his every ability to
send people back south of the border and
he has worked diligently to undermine
many of the same agreements that donald
trump put in place and then of course
joe biden when he gets caught with his
hand in the cookie jar he's had to put
those agreements back in place like the
remain in mexico policy where people are
supposed to wait in mexico before being
granted the capacity to apply for asylum
in the united states gensake was asked
about what was caught on video yesterday
and she said she knows nothing nothing
why is it that large numbers of single
adult men are being released into the
united states just hours after being
apprehended at the southern border
well i'm not sure the specifics of what
you're referring to peter what i can
tell you in terms of what our policy is
and how we're approaching the border is
that we continue to be under title 42
migrants who cannot be expelled under
title 42 are placed into immigration
proceedings and one of those avenues
could be placement in an alternative to
detention program in the interior of the
united states
okay so in other words i don't know
what's going on but also yes we are just
shipping people into the interior of the
united states it's an amazing thing when
this administration is actively
fomenting illegal immigration while
claiming that they are not doing so
which is why you're seeing record
numbers of people attempting to cross
that southern border while joe biden is
president that is what they are they
know this they're saying this they've
said this clearly on video multiple
times we've had interviews with people
asked why they are coming now the answer
is because joe biden is president
it is almost impossible how bad this guy
is at this job
we're in a battle for the culture and
for our values like and subscribe to
help keep our videos on the front line
of the fight and top of your feed